إذا كنت قد فقدت حاسة التذوق أو
الشم مؤخرًا ، فاستمع إلى
مراسلة CNN الصحية جاكلين هوارد
لديها تفاصيل حول كيف أن هذه
الأعراض المحددة قد تكون
الأعراض الوحيدة التي يعاني منها بعض المرضى
بعد الإصابة بفيروس كورونا
جاكلين
بريانا ، فقد أصيب مؤخرًا بفقدان
حاسة التذوق أو
الرائحة.  مفتاح نعلم بالفعل أنه
يمكن أن يكون أحد أعراض مرض كوفيد 19 ،
لكن هذه الدراسة الجديدة توضح بالتفصيل كيف أن
أربعة
من كل خمسة أشخاص يعانون من فقدان
الرائحة أو الذوق مؤخرًا قد يكون اختبار أجسامهم المضادة لـ copa 19 إيجابيًا ،
مما يعني أنهم ربما
أصيبوا بالمرض ، وهذا ما توصلت إليه هذه الدراسة
نظر الباحثون إلى 567 شخصًا في
لندن فقدوا حاسة الشم أو التذوق مؤخرًا
بين هؤلاء الأشخاص ، وحوالي 78 شخصًا
لديهم 19 نوعًا من الأجسام المضادة بين أولئك الذين لديهم
أجسام مضادة ، وحوالي 40 بالمائة ليس لديهم
تاريخ من
السعال أو الحمى ، ووجدت الدراسة أيضًا أن
فقدان حاسة الشم كان أكثر انتشارًا.  من
فقدان
حاسة التذوق ، كان الأشخاص الذين فقدوا حاسة الشم أكثر عرضة
بثلاث مرات
لامتلاك أجسام مضادة مقارنة
بأولئك
الذين فقدوا حاسة
التذوق.
قد لا يكون الأمر متروكًا للرئيس وحده أو
حتى إدارة الغذاء والدواء لهذا الأمر
لأن هناك مجموعة سرية صغيرة
ترى بيانات اللقاح
قبل أي شخص آخر يتم تحديد كل هذا من
قبل مجموعة تسمى
لوحة مراقبة البيانات والسلامة Dsmb
كما هو معروف هي مجموعة من الخبراء في
جميع أنواع المجالات
مثل تطوير لقاح أخلاقيات الإحصاء ،
فهم الوحيدون الذين يحصلون على عدد قليل من
النظرات غير المعماة على
البيانات عندما تبدأ في الظهور يعرفون من
حصلوا على اللقاح
الذي حصلوا على الدواء الوهمي ، فهم هم الذين
يكتشفون ما إذا كان الوقت قد حان للقول
بأن هذا الأمر ناجح وليس قرارًا سياسيًا ،
فهم هم الذين يمكنهم
تقديم المشورة للشركات للتقدم بطلب مراجعة إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
أو قد يحضرون تجربة إلى  توقف
، والآن لديهم واحدة من أكثر
المهام الضخمة في العالم ،
نريد أن نعرف أنهم
مستقلون تمامًا أنه ليس لديهم علاقات سابقة
مع الشركة
حتى لا يتعارضوا معها
بأي طريقة يمر أعضاء مجلس الإدارة
بعملية تدقيق شاملة إلى حد ما ، ولكن
ربما تكون هذه هي أكبر الأسئلة التي
يمكن الوثوق بها في dsmb إذا كانت لديهم
صراعات مالية أو سياسية ، هل يمكن
أن يتعرضوا للضغوط ،
ما لا يريدونه هو أعضاء
لجنتهم  أن تكون محاصرًا من قبل
أشخاص خارجيين
يحاولون معرفة ما يجري
في التجارب عادةً
ما تظل أسماؤهم سرية
أثناء الدراسة ولكن سوزان إلينبرج
التي تعمل في covid19dsmbs
وافقت على التحدث إلينا كيف يمكنك
تمييز
قوة هذا المنتدى؟  تعتقد أنك تشعر
بالقوة
وتشعر بالمسؤولية ، فأنت تعلم أن
الجميع يثقون بك بهذه البيانات
عندما تنظر إلى البيانات ، وأعتقد أن
هناك دائمًا تصورًا بالتأكيد
بين الأشخاص العاديين
أنه موضوعي تمامًا هو أنه
حقًا هذا الهدف بالطبع
هناك درجة من الموضوعية
دعوة للحكم
وهذه هي الطريقة التي تعمل بها هذه
اللجان ولا أرى أي
سبب لتأخيرها أكثر
قالت إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) بشكل أساسي أنه من
المعقول جدًا الانتظار
والمراقبة لمدة شهرين قبل
تفويض أي
شيء قال الرئيس أنك تعلم أنه قد
لا يوافق على
هذه الإرشادات ، فماذا يحدث إذن
ما هو
دور dsmb في مثل هذا الموقف الذي
لم نقم به مطلقًا  كنت في موقف
يبدو أن القيادة الوطنية
منخرطة فيه بشكل مباشر في هذه
الأنواع من العمليات ،
ما سيحدث ثانيًا لا أعرف
أنه كان
dsmb هو الذي دعا إلى إيقاف
محاكمة astrazeneca مؤقتًا عندما كان يتمتع
بصحة جيدة سابقًا
أصيبت امرأة تبلغ من العمر عامًا بحالة عصبية
في المملكة
المتحدة وكان قرارًا حاسمًا حتى لو
حدث عكسي يحدث
بشكل غير متكرر مثل شخص واحد من بين كل عشرة
آلاف
شخص أو واحد من كل عشرين ألف شخص من
شأنه أن يكون عددًا كبيرًا
من الأشخاص الذين سيكون لديهم
عواقب وخيمة.  في حال أكد كبار الأطباء في البلاد
أنهم لن يقطعوا أي زوايا فيما يتعلق
بالسلامة ،
لكن الأمر في الوقت الحالي في أيدي
إيلينبرغ وأعضاء آخرين من نحل dsm
للتأكد من أن هذه هي الحالة ، أعتقد
أننا في منطقة مجهولة
هنا ، هذا هو من يعرف
ما الذي ستفعله الإدارة
منذ اللحظة التي تبدأ فيها في إظهار
الأعراض الأولى
التي تظهر عليها أعراض فيروس كورونا ، وكم من
الوقت تفعل في هذه المرحلة  نعتقد أنك
معدي ،
فأنت تعلم أه جون يختلف حقًا من
شخص لآخر ،
ما يحدث عادةً هو أنك تتعرض
بعد يومين للفيروس
يتكاثر
في مجرى الهواء العلوي لديك ويمكن أن تكون
معديًا
لأشخاص آخرين لمدة يوم أو يومين قبل ذلك.
تحصل فعليًا على الأعراض
بمجرد ظهور الأعراض لديك ، وهذا
متوسط حوالي خمسة أي
م هو متوسط الوقت من التعر
لتعبير الأعراض ثم بعد بض
ة أيام قد تكو
مريضًا ومع ذلك لم يعد الفيروس قابلاً للانت
ال لأننا فعلنا  دراسا
عندما تحاول عزل الفيروس من
البلعوم الأنفي
عندما يكون الأشخاص في حالة مرضية
أو يتعافون
ولا يكون لديك ، لذلك عادة ما يكون ذلك
قبل ظهور الأعراض
ولعدة أيام
بعد ذلك ، تكون الإرشادات العامة هي
متى يكون من الآمن أن يخرج الشخص
من الوقت الذي تظهر عليه الأعراض ، فمن
المحتمل أن يكون حوالي
10 أيام من بداية ظهور الأعراض ،
وعادةً لا يكون لديك أي فيروس وفي الدراسات
التي أجريت
تلك  الناس عمومًا ليسوا معديين على الإطلاق
لأشخاص آخرين ،
السكرتير أليكس عازار والطبيب
الذي يبدو أن الرئيس يستمع
إلى معظم وقت
متأخر طبيب الأشعة الدكتور سكوت أطلس الذي التقوا به
مع العديد من العلماء هذا الأسبوع
الذين يدافعون عن
مناعة القطيع وأنا أعرف فريقك  لقد
نظر في الفكرة الكاملة لمناعة القطيع
وما قد يبدو عليه
ذلك في الواقع في هذا البلد إذا اخترنا هذا المسار ،
ما الذي تفعله
جيدًا ، علينا أن نكون واضحين حقًا
ما نعنيه بمناعة القطيع لأن
هناك
طريقتان  يستخدم الأشخاص المصطلح الأول هو أنك
تعرف
عدد الأشخاص الذين يجب أن يصابوا بالعدوى أو يتم
تطعيمهم قبل
أن نعرف وقف انتقال العدوى والآخر
كاستراتيجية واستراتيجية يعني ذلك ببساطة
عدم القيام بأي شيء والسماح للفيروس
بالمرور عبر السكان ، لكن
هذه وصفة لعدد كبير
من الوفيات في البلد
فقط ، هل يمكنك أن تشرح أنها تقول إن أربعين في
المائة تؤذي المناعة ، وأن أربعين في
المائة من السكان
قد تكبدوا
815000  تتضاعف الوفيات أساسًا إذا كانت 60
ستكون أكثر
من مليون 200000 زائد
نعم ، ويمكننا إجراء هذه
الحسابات لأننا نعرف
جيدًا من الدراسات الاستقصائية
حول الأجسام المضادة التي نعرف جيدًا
معدل الوفيات حسب العمر وهكذا  يمكننا أن نأخذ
معدل الوفيات هذا حسب العمر ،
كم عدد الأشخاص الذين
سيصابون بالعدوى قبل أن تتأذى مناعة
وإجراء هذه الحسابات ، لذا فهي
مزعجة للغاية لأنه حتى
وجهة النظر الأكثر تفاؤلاً ، دعنا نقول
أنك تعرف كما قلت 40 فهي تشير إلى
أننا  ليس بعيدًا جدًا في
الوباء حتى الآن في الولايات المتحدة ،
فأنت تعلم أنه مثير للاهتمام دكتور موراي
لأنه كان يشير إلى هذا الاجتماع
حيث
كانت الخطة أو  كانت الإستراتيجية هي
عزل الأشخاص المستضعفين بشكل
صحيح والذين يمثلون حوالي 40 في المائة من
السكان بناءً على العمر والظروف الموجودة مسبقًا
عزلهم ولكن المضي قدمًا والسماح
للمدارس بفتحها ،
على سبيل المثال ، مما يجعل من
الممكن أن يصبح الشباب أساسًا قطيعًا.
تخمين الحماية
حول الفئات الأكثر ضعفًا
التي تسمعها كثيرًا وأعتقد أن هذا ما
كان يشير إليه الوزير عازار
هو أن لديهم نفس المشاكل
التي تصفها
جيدًا كما تعلمون في عالم نظري
حيث كل شخص ضعيف  أنت
تعلم أن جميع الأشخاص الذين تزيد أعمارهم عن 65 عامًا
والذين يعانون من أمراض مصاحبة لا يتواصلون
مع أي شخص آخر ،
ربما يكون ذلك ممكنًا ولكن هذا
ليس ما نراه في أي بلد ،
ما يحدث عندما يكون هناك الكثير من
انتقال المرض
كما رأينا في فلوريدا لدى الشباب
في  في وقت مبكر من شهر يوليو ،
تصل في النهاية إلى الأشخاص في
المنزل ، الآباء الذين تعرفهم الأصدقاء الأكبر سنًا ،
وذلك عندما نبدأ
في رؤية الوفيات تتزايد